I started out my first film job was on
gangs in New York which was a Martin
Scorsese film which shot in Rome where I
was living and to cut a long story short
I ended up on the production for seven
months and got into thermo Schumacher's
editing room and every time I went in
that I got very excited and also I saw
dailies every day and seeing what he
acquired and then thinking about how he
was going to reduce that because I was
in a camera department I was thinking
about camera and I realized I couldn't
do the numbers but the editing was that
was where I was what I was interested in
and then and then I trust that's when I
started to pursue it
in terms of your development in terms at
this point would you say that was a kind
of a a mixture of educational and sort
of honed skill I mean look I was very
very very short that I wanted to make
films okay which is why I got very
depressed working in commercials because
nobody cares about the work ever do they
pay you a lot but then the work is
always just and that was very depressing
to me so that I can't accomplish you
this and I can't seriously pursue it
because I just want to cut my wrists
yeah but getting a film was just a piece
of luck because I didn't really know
people in the big one friend who was
producing in London and I didn't live in
London it was blind like that Nicolas
needed an editor and and I moved to
London to do that and he left me but it
was it was very much like okay I mean I
gotta go yeah I met Nick because he came
to London to do a Miss Marple my friend
was the producer about them and my
friend said here's Matt and Nicola I
have to say was very different he was
just like yeah sure haha and I hadn't
cut a feature I'd just done lots of
commercials but I was like sure and then
he called me for Bronson and then he
kept calling
I'm very masterly aren't you mind if I
yeah I'm doing wrong my god it's huge
sometimes a freedom do you think oh yeah
go with Nicky country wouldn't have
gotten you think well like I can't say
because I don't know the directors you
here I know for a fact that Scorsese is
in the editing room a lot and he once he
likes it he wants to be in the editing
room other directors come in to make
final cut I've heard horror stories
about directors that are like do you
mind if I set it to avid and you know
you can go and get a tea and then for
editors like everyone every director has
his own process and I know what next
process is and for me that means I have
a lot of freedom but that is also comes
from the fact that Nick and I have
discovered we have the same taste nick
has a very specific taste and a certain
idea about how a movie should look and I
found out because I've learned
everything I know from this guy in terms
of like how you shoot a movie but then
how you put it together is is kind of
like it's just looked at I kind of
understood what he was going for and
knew how to do it in a certain way
coming quite early in the process and
the development or you know do you come
in when they start shooting yeah I mean
he he always that's my opinion on the
script and I have to say that he's very
good at not listening to me because I
told him what to do trash
clip the first version of the script I
didn't like it was a studio action film
well it was really trashy and I said
Nicky this is awful
we said yeah but it's Ryan and we're
gonna change it so it's not okay but
don't do this when this one is awful guy
a man in a car in LA could be cool so
but this could the first script was it
was it was a studio it's like a Hugh
Jackman action film and it was ghastly
out there that you cannot lock the
dialogue like something like 50 or 60
percent yeah it didn't end up in the fun
it was the script that's yeah but the
firt were the first scripts was just was
like a smartass Hollywood script where
every time somebody said something the
driver had a one-liner
but that went very quickly and it went
back to the book where the driver was
much more mysterious but he even talks a
lot in the book but basically with Ryan
once they started shooting I know that
Ryan was like can I just not say
anything and then and it turned and that
was really working and then they would
come in and watch it and that's the
direction they went in director wants to
see a rollover you okay with that
remember if you don't feel good just
abort the shot there's no shame in that
right
I mean you're you're doubling for the
start you know like a gay player in it
and I got your 500 more huh of course we
split that you okay ready to go all
right
countin on it I mean a lot of people saw
drivers hated it I know a lot of people
had a hard time with Valhalla and just
their not easy movies they're extremely
you have to go to the film lots of
commercial productions and it's no knock
against them but they come and sit in
your lap it's really they do everything
they can to ingratiate themselves to you
because they want you to like the film
they want you to be involved in it could
care less
he wants the movie to be good for itself
and so they can be very I think they can
be quite stony
if you're not if you don't like that
attitude of the film I personally love
it but yeah I mean my father didn't get
Valhalla he was just like I couldn't you
you know it's just knocking against a
glass wall
when I died well Hara is basically
thinking on - because there was like a
whole sea my guys like I know I know it
was an individual how do you sort of
well look when you see it the first
obviously it and this is what has to be
there were you know this is an editing
yourself those things never have any
impact outside of the context of the
film's ever when they shot that it was
pig goes I mean you just you just look
at it and go but you react the same way
you would if you saw a chicken getting
its neck snapped it's not emotional it's
just it's just gross and you know you're
doing it right when you see it in the
context of the film and you're shocked
so the the I'm trying to think I mean in
Valhalla that's horrible and he that
came down to an argument about frames
you know more goats know less cuts more
goats less goods but then other things
in that film I didn't it's not a violent
movie apart from that yeah where's Drive
once that gets going and the thing is is
that and I have to say this I know it's
kind of graphic but I watched Fast Five
recently and that film was violent that
was just people running around with with
machine guns shooting everybody I mean
it was just the body count in that movie
was absurd but it was fun the violence
was part of the fun and it's okay I mean
that's like a certain like way of
washing the genre of film and the thing
is in Drive you spent the first hour
you've told it's a drama and you totally
if you liked the film you believe in
those people so all you need is that I
saw this all said I would because it's
like no word that Shannon and it's not
actually that nasty it's just this you
know it's not you know someone's head
exposed but that's when I knew like okay
we got it because everybody was shocked
I was getting excited about this whole
thing my name on a car I mean look how
beautiful
I wanted to see my name on this thing I
think we would have made a go with this
business
that you use didn't as become a mulligan
you edited yeah didn't film it until it
was annexed house we set up at his house
and and he would shoot and come back I
forget why Carrie was there I think she
didn't ever place she didn't have a
place in LA and the production offered
her something but Nick was just like you
could stay and because his family wasn't
there so she just stayed she made
everyone carrot cake she's really nice
she didn't have many days she's not in
the film that much so she she was there
and just hung out and then she hung out
because she was in LA and she was
waiting for a next job and Ryan came by
a lot when Ryan would talk about it that
was strange because he would talk about
I think the driver here and he talks
about the character in the third person
it would never say look I'm not good in
that tape he's looking at it in a
certain way look how it's fitting into
the film as well I think he's very good
at the big picture so but yeah I don't
go to the set for example because then
you suddenly you know I was there for
the motel stuff
the shootout in the motel and I remember
how small the room was and how difficult
it was to get that and then of course
you're sitting there looking at it and
immediately invade your consciousness
and some editors have founded that but
that's a problem for me when I when I
know what it took to get a shot rather
than just seeing is the shot of value to
the way to tell the story
so it sounds like a fantastic working
relationship has it been any timed at
all yeah but that's the weird thing is
is it's not a contentious relationship
because first of all Nick doesn't thrive
on on conflict and I know what a lot of
people do and that's good too
you know to be like you know a nun
arguing but Nick's not an argue I he if
if you make a case for something that he
doesn't like her go away and think about
you for two days there were things that
I offered him on drive-in music but at
the beginning in editing choices he's
just like really but he wouldn't just go
oh okay let me let me think about it
did you work with that music that was
the big part of yeah
so what happened was when I arrived at
first
sniffing Ryan senator shows your iTunes
library
Bryan hired Nicholls he called him she
loved him to do this movie one of the
reasons we the reason was France you
reason allele of Bransford one of the
reasons he loved the statistical this
the impact of that film the way there's
music in it it's kind of a crazy movie
and they were thinking the same drive
that we would have this in electronic
soundtracks and they were they were
listening to Kraftwerk and all this
other stuff
Nick had already started listening to
this thrashing Europop and I had a bunch
of it and all of those songs that are in
the film we all practically were
listened to on the first two nights that
we got together and made our top ten
we're just lot are these are great and
they're getting the film somehow and
then it was just deployment and the
third the night call track which opened
which is the the title sequence that's
when I knew how the film was gonna feel
and when I showed it to Nick as well he
was just like we're done
you